Claude Code is [music] an agentic coding
tool that understands your code base,
edits your files, run commands, and
integrates with your existing developer
tools to help you get things done
faster.
It's available in your terminal, Visual
Studio Code, the Claude desktop app, on
the web, and JetBrains IDEs.
>> [music]
>> But, we'll be using it in the terminal
for this video.
If you've ever used Claude AI, you're
probably wondering what the difference
is between the two. Unlike Claude AI,
Claude Code has direct access to your
files in your terminal and your entire
code base. So, instead of copying and
pasting code back and forth, it can go
in and do all the work itself. The
easiest differentiator is that Claude
Code works as an AI agent.
An AI agent is a software that can
interact with its environment and
perform actions to complete a defined
goal. The most basic way this can be
done is by having a large language model
in a loop in real time. AI agents have
access to things like tools, external
services, or other AI agents to help it
reach its predefined goals.
So, what does that actually look like?
Well, here's a couple of examples. It
can read and understand your code base.
You can ask Claude Code to explain a
feature or trace a bug throughout your
code. Claude Code can execute your build
script, run your tests, install
packages, and use the output to decide
what to do next.
Claude Code can search the web. If it
needs documentation on the latest API
references, for example, it can do that
for you.
To use Claude Code effectively, it's
important to know these concepts. First
is the context window.
Think of this as Claude's working
memory. It can hold a lot, but not
everything at once.
This is where the agentic aspect of it
comes in. Finding strategic ways to find
the answers within your code base
without storing your entire code base
into context. Second is that it asks for
permission.
By default, Claude Code will ask you
before running commands or making
changes to your code base. You're always
in control, whether that's being more
hands-on or passive.
Third, it can make mistakes.
Just like any tool, Claude Code isn't
perfect. It might misunderstand your
intent, introduce a new bug, or
over-engineer a solution.
Quick recap. Claude Code is an agentic
coding tool. It reads your code base,
edits your files, runs commands, [music]
and connects to external tools to help
you ship faster.
You can download it today in your
terminal, VS Code, JetBrains, [music]
and the Claude desktop app.